I've been searching for something to take or do to help a severe birding pain.
I get in my thighs when I walk.
Nothing has helped the pain either strong narcotics or any stignatural and suspicious
that it could be from the baritonella that I have.
Would it be okay to try H-box to see if that would help with both the breast cancer?
Diagnosis as well as Lyme and Co-infections
that possibly help with the wrong awful birding pain in my thighs.
Absolutely. So you could for sure, there is no contraindication that H-box for cancer,
any type of cancer. I would also consider running the baritonella program
the right during the day. Think about that if that is an issue.
Run the pain program on the right. Run other Lyme Co-infections on the right.
See if that makes a difference as well.